From the architectonic point of view, this room is conceived lower and narrower.
The presence of irons and shackles testifies the character of this invasion.
The Ottomans infiltrated Europe at the end of 14th century.
In 1372 in Marica, in 1385 in Saver, Lushnia, in 1389 the Battle of Fusha Kosova where the
Albanians were distinguished in an anti-Ottoman coalition, where an Albanian from Kosova named
Milos Kopili succeeded in killing Sultan Maradi I. Kruja was invaded in the year 1415.
This room includes map of the Ottoman invasion, the war cry of Arbor Mosaic,
the fireplace of Castriot, a sword donated to the Ferdinand of Naples reproduction.
At the entrance of unification endurance room are exposed two authentic bells, 14th century.
George Castrioti, 1405-1468, was the youngest son of John Castrioti who was the leader of
the princedom in Middle Albania. His first possessions were two villages in Dibra village,
Senia and Gardi Pashtem. When John Castrioti was under the vassalage of Sultan Maradi II,
he was obliged to give away as hostages his four sons to the Sultan, and George was one of them.
The Ottomans sent him to the military school of Iklans. They named him Iskander, which
corresponds to the Christian name of Alexander. Later, they gave him the military grade Beg,
that is why he is known by the name Skanderbeg.